I was adopted in the valley and you
heard what your what your guys yes the
universe
when I was five you for five days but uh
and you stayed with mama with that
mostly with mom but dad - how was your
childhood perfectly fine
I accepted everything I covered up with
doing sports and tours everything that's
in my head in mine and I couldn't
explain it all the abuse stuff this okay
what kind of abuse
search for physical everything in one I
don't want to tell the truth but I need
to tote you both and one more yeah I
don't know
so there were sexual news mm-hmm
was it ongoing mm-hmm they have some
drop can I do some drugs please
how do I can I go get it yeah no you
have a poopy pipe
there's only drag I have with me right
now okay I [ __ ] and piss myself and
turn deaf yesterday and and threw up at
the same time someone drugged me someone
did something to me or ASA I don't know
but I did everything at once and I
survived it they're not trying to lie no
more try and tell the Jews try to cover
up all the [ __ ] they put me through
here without feeling like I'm a cop so I
don't want to turn to the other side or
turn the other side I just want to do me
three five years in SRO two years and a
three years on the street intent nothing
but everything in some ways it depends
on a month and a week sure I would love
to have sure because I feel like that's
gonna help me and I'm focused and I can
do everything perfectly fine with it
you sure yes it means me pavley's we go
just makes me complete my mission it
makes me feel good it makes me cover up
all my other drug stuff and makes me not
cry
yes sometime yeah I guess I just feel
powerful when you smoke it but I'm good
with numbers
I'm very good I have a talent in numbers
and if I just do it right with the
surrender or measure it right I hope you
perfectly fine and everyone's trying to
stop me because I know I'm doing
something right but I feel like I have
to people and sometimes three and me and
I try to do the same thing once I know
English but I understand Spanish I'm
just trying to do the right thing son
you know I made sure he's perfectly fine
with a great family a family friend
which he's happy and perfect it's gonna
be our history oh yeah Joe John
nan tell you my life ray EBT
or try to do errands for people hustle
the best way I used to try to help
people with medication of weed I'm not
trying to go any further than that and
thank God I hadn't done that
I'm not no homo booster
I don't go stores and steal I know going
cars and hook and I'm proud of it
you know I kept my problem isn't and I'm
keeping it somewhat a month ago there's
an adoption parents but now I know the
truth I'm just trying to meet and trying
to find my family my biological mother
and father but I feel like I'm close
is your dad birth fossil whom my mom
said possible for two years
[Music]
I'm trying not to cry
I'm just a number did your son know that
he's enough do you brothers and sisters
yep he ever talks about here and there
um recently I've been stabbed last year
and then I got closer to my family
excuse me yeah any concern to you today
try get you they try to but I tried do
by myself so I'll give them more stress
you know what they did to me
I just tried do me cuz I'm strong is
this the most I've been way more but yes
this is thick almost then and I know
stuff I had I know things and I knows
I'm almost towards the end
and I'm being strong until I go to
another world
of course I hear it every day